[Music]
Shannon beador is back Season 13 and I
gotta say the last time I saw you I
thought you and Vicki were done for good
I know
then the reunion happened this is good
guys okay this is healing what was it
about that day at the reunion that
something shifted well for me with Vicki
I saw true emotion come from her when
she heard that David and I had separated
and I mean she she shed tears and so you
know that was that was touching for me I
think that because David and I weren't
together anymore that made the
reconciliation a little bit easier
because you know things were said about
him but I know it's gonna sound insane
but starting a friendship with her again
it was like we're back there wasn't baby
steps all of a sudden you know we spend
time together everything's the way it
used to be Wow I know that's huge
because I have you on camera saying you
will never be friends with sorry I don't
want to be friends with Vicki I will
never ever speak to you again
yeah so it's very different but in terms
of watching the show the show feels fun
again it is I have to tell you from
beginning to end there are some crazy
funny fun times that I had fun filming
so I hope that people have fun watching
it
[Applause]
would you say you are as close as you
used to be I would say that Vicki and I
are as close as we used to be we talk
all the time
no worries there anymore with her you
know no at this point I'm my life is
completely different than it was before
and so I'm moving forward in my life
happy and positive and I I don't want
any negativity nine lemons in a bowl
bring the positivity we got that here
thank you
it does look like there will be
something that goes down between you and
Tamra this this is what I think a test
of a good friendship is because Tamra is
one of my best friends we talk every
single day and you know just like a
family member or anything you're gonna
have ups and downs and and you're gonna
argue so it's how you resolve those
arguments and how quickly you can move
forward from them so we're in a good
place right now that's all what are you
most dreading having to watch back this
year I am dreading the Jamaica trip can
you one word while you're dreading it
reactive I was reactive
on the flip side what are you looking
most forward to seeing back well I'm the
fun
Tamra Vicki and I we can't wait to see
what happens in Mexico because we don't
really remember all the details which is
frightening gonna kiss me but you know
what you're entitled to go out and go
crazy for a couple days you just as long
as you don't do it all the time I acted
like a sick 18 21 year old and you
weren't the one who broke her foot no no
I might have be the one in a Spanx and
right next to the naked
[Music]
[Applause]